[Music]
in spooky X news X like X past X or Lee
thanks gonna give it to you submitted by
sip is Bom
thank you very much chair you what smile
sip matcha a man has been arrested after
pretending to be his ex-fiance's mothers
it goes okay what why
so he's haunting his ex-fiancee attended
to be the mom yeah so he was pretending
to be a dead person and that dead person
was a female but he was a male well it
was through letters Oh letters ghosts
right yeah exactly it's a ghost rider
should have been a better title than its
ghost rider news so this man he poses
his ex-fiancee his dead mother through
letters that were given to her through a
psychic oh boy he paid off a psychic
fake psychic I don't know exactly they
don't really like go into yeah but those
are the things that matter
sure they do come on they don't tell us
exactly what was in these letters but
the ex-fiance says that she knows they
were from him because they're included
details that only he knew about to bid
and so like the whole point of this
whole thing is that he was trying to win
her back
that's like me it's like me trying to
haunt her and all of my letters have
Bear talk in it your grandma cuny thank
you nee it's like these two quotes from
these letters one of them is that he
speaks of a man who sacrificed
everything for you that's great he's
talking himself oh em gee can't you see
the great om Jesus she's like talks with
Jim emoji of greatness in this man stop
puttin hashtags in there I just would
imagine he is the best lover you on the
planet you should probably we're happy
[ __ ] idiot yeah so yeah
I pictured her like reading this like
this [ __ ]
alright I gotta [ __ ] go talk to him
then [ __ ] tell him to stop doing this
[ __ ] so she knocks on the door and he's
like oh [ __ ] it worked
you see what the [ __ ] he comes up with
well the reason why he in trouble
oh the reason why you got arrested is
because he broke the terms of a
restraining order by sending these
letters I mean that sounds that sounds
like some stalker s behavior like boos
that cannot let go don't find some
[ __ ] way to stay in the life like as
a ghost in [ __ ] like it was gonna be
like a legit like phone call like you're
like shaking shaking some of the wall
you're but yeah so this is Roy Roy you
look like a weirdo come on Roy you're
too old for this wrong that's it's too
big for you 51 years old girl he's
trying to get back Jesus Christ you
trying to get back with his ex-wife
ex-fiance ex-fiance they didn't even get
to wife dad that's odd that's why do he
looks like a politician I really do have
you ever tried the turkey pot pie the
light Edition it's only like that's what
you're coming up with what we're talking
it's only 500 calories because I'm on a
diet cause I'm on a diet right it's only
on 500 calories hey we're talkin soup
the chicken pot pies pretty good
check it out turkey how about cheesecake
he likes their Caesar salads the best
kale salad the best kale salad the
vinaigrette I like their Shepherd pie
and soup and salad combo and then you
get a free pie I like their peach
cobbler I only have one dish their
coolers bomb what is it chicken farfalle
oh I like that dude my the pasta DaVinci
has been what I've been eating since I
was 17 years old what is that it's in a
Madeira wine sauce I used to work at
she's contracted I still love that [ __ ]
with a dash of
Oh mushrooms from Tuscany it's a pasta
penne pasta with chicken and mushrooms
and a white sausage it's [ __ ] bomb
Brown chocolate bread - what is that
oh yeah it's nobody ever knew what that
bread was called I thought that's
Outback it's like a wheat bread no one
with the oats on it yeah this [ __ ]
thirsty ass [ __ ] over here like he is
he going to jail or anything he violated
a restraining order what he have a
restraining order
I don't know she's just being a pervert
wait so did she know right off the bat
of course well yeah because he was
mentioning things that only he would
know it's pretty obvious one night when
he ate your ass and you loved it those
are reference to a Christmas ornament
which was left to her by her mother and
he fixed that Christmas ornament and he
referenced that somehow in the letters
the worst criminal in I still don't get
the letter part how dumb is he what
ghosts right let his handwriting yeah oh
my god imagine he was Barbara and him
was Jim and then he write loved grandma
or some [ __ ] this was sending ghost
emails and [ __ ] like your grandma goes
to at gmail.com how do you get so far
gone that you think this is a good idea
of how [ __ ] bad people want to stay
connected
it's so [ __ ] crazy I need friends
like this they entertained that love you
that much no I think watching people
that like are extremely creative because
of where they are in life I don't think
they're creative though I think
desperation will just cause you do
anything anything rather than finding
the best way but there get creative
because they're so desperate I don't
know yet grown man like crawling into a
tree to get into the window that is
hilarious do you guys know anyone who's
like who's always complained to you guys
about a crazy girlfriend or something a
boyfriend and they end up getting back
with them oh that they end up getting
back with I feel like in high school I
had a lot of friends all my friends
it's been a long time since I've been
around 80 it's a legit help someone like
hey Jim can you help me get a
restraining order before I'm like okay
this is what you do is what you do is
what you do
last I heard you got back with her like
you know at this point you deserve it I
hope those rights deal yeah because I
remember having friends that would like
talk about their ex or their boyfriend
like so [ __ ] bad now so I'm just like
damn you should leave them girl like
that's that's crazy and then they get
back with them yeah you know I didn't I
feel like I wasted my time in my act
like why the [ __ ] did you even tell me
your [ __ ] exactly as cool a person that
asks for something but then they don't
even yeah like an [ __ ] yeah they go
back on whatever you just kind of like
you just ruin all the concern I had for
you because it wasn't that bad for you
to go back that same person I want so
much like your attention is that the
same person I would turn back to a piece
of [ __ ] they'd literally just want your
attention they want your fake pity to
make them feel good they want that
attention that I'm gonna go back to guy
that punches I'm gonna teeth that's so
weird what some desperation okay [ __ ]
yes we do yeah we see we told this guy
like not to come back you know like to
the area that we're in just make people
feel uncomfortable yeah yeah yeah
because he just basically broke up with
one of our friends and then we're like
nah man you can't come back right now
because it's too fresh like give us some
time and then what do you do Joe what do
you do he came back with me when and a
couple of us were gone and then we had
to come back like what the [ __ ] where
that's weird like you were asked not to
come it's not like playing hard to get
where you have to prove your love to
them it's literally just [ __ ] give it
some time man we're like being cute like
showing some kind of like like you
really care for somebody is different
when it when you cross a social norm you
don't get a social note norm or in your
case even telling them like you guys
should come back but you should feel the
energy I probably shouldn't do that
that's what that's when that stop you
stop yourself it's not a bollywood movie
where the girls playing hard-to-get and
she's like
you don't mean like the [ __ ] really
[ __ ] room weird all here is there is
one guy that I dated that um I would I
tell you don't talk to me again go kill
yourself it's probably a good link takes
you in 24 yeah right look maybe you
should not so like every three months or
so he's like hey it's me or like hey I
know you probably don't want to talk to
me but it's me I'm like which part of
[ __ ] and go kill yourself do you not
[ __ ] understand welcome they'll be
like me you achieve numbers all the time
all the time maybe she needs time to
cool off is what they're thinking yeah
right
[ __ ] off had died is not me and Hank
maybe try again later
just just needs a good like five years
should be okay after that it's weird how
people obsess over like one person to
the point of like they stop acting like
a human yeah that's just really [ __ ]
weird
and it's crazy because like people
capitalize on that behavior and then
they make shows like The Bachelor and
the Bachelorette Cissna on there's
something in paradise or something like
that and you see that behavior that
thirsty behavior on there and I'm like
that's [ __ ] sad it's where that some
people aren't like on the internet now
or kind of proud of it like I'm crazy I
don't care you know like it's just like
no [ __ ] dude I posted a meme or it was
like my boyfriend's not allowed and I
feel like girls like this exist where my
boyfriend's not allowed to have a
birthday cake because what should he be
wishing for it like you he already has
that really yeah yeah it's that one me
my used to love that [ __ ] thing about
the Incredibles
with frozen honey it's my super Sam the
greatest good therefore there's like
girls who are just like when my man and
I it's my man I break up I'm gonna make
sure he's never happy again cuz I'm
crazy
hashtag lol crazy it's like no [ __ ] off
you psychopath like it's not funny and
it's not cute
what the hell's wrong with you no you
know what's even worse than that the
people that encourage that right oh yes
oh Christ I think it's funny it's good
content for your submission it's so
entertaining cuz I'm just like it's
entertainment you don't even like it
yeah it's [ __ ] up or whatever but like
to think like that's like Jersey Shore
[ __ ] like that's popular because it's so
wild and it's so out of the norm that
you're just like so
trees and fat like what the hell I I do
keep a couple of people I do keep a
couple people on my facebook slowly
because of entertainment of course you
do it is this is one girl we had a
stalker and she's like oh my god
I don't know why I have such a stalker
you tagged yourself everywhere you go
you dumb [ __ ]
hope you can't find me like I'm cosine
and sparkers here oh my god which I did
not see every two days like oh my god
guys what should I see what should I do
and then everyone give her advices
they're stupid they buy into it and then
eventually they dude killed himself
whatever and then she goes I can't
believe he killed himself I feel like I
need to go to the funeral because
partially it was because of me should I
go to the funeral and I called her out
I'm like either you're [ __ ] stupid or
you want attention and then she des
leave it like you're what the [ __ ] are
you thinking yeah she's so stupid
but she's also one of those girls I've
been on the news multiple times because
something terrible always happens to her
yeah so she finds attention through [ __ ]
like that I think that's what most of it
is just like people wanting attention
look at me I'm so special and so wanted
I think are you really dumb you can't
entertain yourself by doing productive
things or even entertain yourself by
sitting by yourself and so all you
create drama cuz that's the only way
that your dumb ass can handle life Jo or
you actually go insane and they're a
combo of insane that was deep pretty
deep like smiley usually dumb people are
the ones that really like drama yeah one
episode that's how they entertain
themselves rather than like getting a
skill of finding a hobby that like or
even just be able to be okay with
yourself in your head for a while yeah
yeah
were you really dumb there's nothing
going on to him that's deep I have
feature films happening in my head
[Music]